let's go to the Discord phone lines and
hear from some of the folks in our
audience we do this on the Friday show
you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord that is the place for it let's
start today with Bert from New Jersey
Bert welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey David hear me okay yes I can
okay
uh two questions uh comes from the Trump
Town Hall a couple weeks ago yes CNN
more
curious about your opinion
um my opinion is there's been a lot of
uh pushback from the CNN people that you
know how dare you give this guy a
platform you know
um basically empowering him
you know most of the time you hear a
trump interview he's talking to Sean
Hannity he's talking to Tucker Carlson
it's like a uh I don't know Kim Jong-un
being interviewed by North Korean State
media right you're not getting any real
substance wait a look at it we were able
to see him actually push for once right
and he had to actually like respond to
same election was stolen and you know
saying he can wave his hand and uh
declassify documents right so like for
me there was value and seeing him having
to actually be confronted with this
stuff and like talk about it
um left me feeling like like to see it
again you know like curious if you
thought the same or if you got the same
reaction out of that yeah I mean here's
the thing in principle I agree with you
and there was some pushback the problem
is and you know Caitlin Collins who
hosted it has gotten a lot of the
criticism I don't know that any single
person
Trump lies so much that it's a bigger
task than any one person can handle to
actually do justice to what should be
the amount of pushback that he should be
getting it's it's it's an impossible
position to be in and so while on the
one hand you're right he was quote
confronted with the reality that nobody
nobody in any kind of position of
authority has found any wrongdoing with
2020 or whatever the case may be it
really wasn't enough and his supporters
saw it and they were emboldened by how
he wasn't gonna submit to CNN and
whatever so I I don't know if it really
did any more good than it did harm that
being said CNN has every right to do
town halls with you know they're doing
one with Nikki Haley they're doing one
with Pence even though Pence hasn't
announced like it's not that CNN
shouldn't be doing these events it's
just really hard to do it justice and do
it responsibly
right
yeah no that's totally fair totally fair
um and the other thing I was I was gonna
ask you too is uh for yourself as you're
sitting there watching this right do you
ever feel like kind of conflicted
because on one side you know you the
man's uh policy is to you repulsive
everything about him is terrible
but at the same time he gives you
material right and it's like it's
exciting to talk about and it's it's uh
gives you like uh so much spark right so
do you ever fear yourself not I'm not
gonna say rooting for him but like as
much as you hate him part of his like
well you know this is great he's back we
can talk about these things out is that
you ever get that feeling I don't get
the grade he's back thing I mean here
here's the thing I have no controller
say over whether Trump's a candidate I
don't and I have no controller say
whether corporate media gives the guy
attention I do a show there are always
things happening in this country there
will always be things to talk about and
so is Trump entertaining in a very kind
of disturbing way where you laugh to
avoid crying absolutely do I I don't
feel conflicted because I have
absolutely no involvement in the fact
that this guy is running again and he
has tens of millions of supporters so I
100 agree with what you're saying but I
don't I don't have any kind of internal
conflict no
awesome awesome cool all right Bert from
Jersey thank you very much great to hear
from you plastic it's everywhere we look
and not enough is being done about it
100 billion plastic bags are used and
thrown away every year here's something
super simple you can do to reduce
plastic and help the planet a little bit
our sponsor hold on bags is the company
making plastic free trash bags and zip
seal kitchen bags they're just as strong
and high quality as the plastic bags
you're used to hold on bags are 100
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single-use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to holdon bags.com Pacman and
you'll get 20 off with code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below